the first time you met Justin Bieber
this kid comes up to you he's not Justin
Bieber yet he's just some kid and he
says I want to sing for you it was at
the studio of Jermaine Dupri's I said
you know why don't you set up a meeting
between me and your manager I love to
meet with you and do this in a formal
setting I'm late for an appointment with
your may Dupree right and I don't want
to keep him waiting let's just do this
the right way and then you haven't come
to audition for you right actually a few
people my wife at the time right at us
also was Perri Reed LA Reed's
first wife we were all sitting in a room
Slee in a room yeah and I showed her the
video and Perry says are you crazy you
better get down there meet this kid
right now he's amazing
when all these dick pecs come out and
all this stuff with Bieber's big penis
are you the mastermind behind that say
listen show off your big penis when
people try to that package or are you
sitting there yeah sure you sitting down
with him and saying yeah show your [ __ ]
or leave it in your pants you sit him
down and say look that's his PR by the
way since he does have a brain of his
own yeah but were you shocked at the
time of his piece hey listen he has a
mind of his own what he chose to do with
his penis is his prerogative he's
managing that aspect of his life but I'm
sure something and nothing to do with
Justin Bieber's private parts man come
on